all right I'm doing a lot of writing and
planning
how about 4 a.m. 1 to 4 tonight how about
things that again in my head on this
has to be talking through it while I do it
but had the goal for the evening is
how to plan a substantial part of the Boost
outline which sham
you know it's is what we doing in May so
that's what the countdown timer is about we
learn days until we start the new say I was
asleep I had to
I had a pretty vivid dream about
the way to have to do this this going to be
easiest
and premier league is going to be moving
away from
Docker for the Boost in 2022 so I need to
rework the counter base than then
the first week of the booths will be
how many cops like when I get to Lenox and
Cody M boost as opposed to being a boost
we can always call it back in beginner boost
but that sounds kind of weird
I'm in infrastructure engineering
this is where we can cover some of the some
of the more Google things to learn
when's the rain going to start with
virtualbox it because we're two boxes in
central driver for both minikube and for
vagrant later and then we do containers in
communities we can we learn about the
technology in the same order that it evolved
so if we had his regular servers and then we
had virtualization and then after that we
had it containerization cell
another thing to is that if someone decides
I want to go little bit further with Lennox
stuff they want to they want to learn how to
create this partitions and they want to run
Arch and do the install excetera they can do
that with her 2 bucks I cannot do that with
make you let me sorry yeah well with Dr any
of those options so
so so we're back to Virtual machines I was
expecting this but I've been really
influence recently by the work I'm doing
with Patron and I realized that Rachel is
nation is the most important technology any
any technologist is going to learn who wants
to be able to try different things
so what does it what does it look like well
let's take a look
when it's over to box that looks like I
still have a bunch of ignorant boxes running
I'm going to go ahead and test this a little
bit I want to check and see if
if you can create a virtual at a volume
without doing the estimate the other stuff
and the first thing when do the Arizona on
it I could go back to my other lab
and I need to make or destroy these
how do I get rid of that
you're the reason for using a VM is because
we can do snapshots and by default virtual
those machines are State full. A femoral a
vagrant records fantastic
not today I'll be doing that for work today
yep right now I'm planning for the next 3
hours and be planning beginner boost stuff
and when I start work sometimes around 9 at
9:10 today I will be doing that yes I'll be
installing kubernetes from scratch on a
system that has an external volume for NFL
that is what we will do
I am trying to see if I can do a video about
this I don't think I'm going to be able to
virtualbox yeah here's a lot on that
I'm also considering migrating all of my
stuff into a single lab Repository
because I have stuff that goes back and
forth between the different labs
hey Tonya
got that going to do that right now I'm
going to migrate all of my lab content into
a single repo called lab
yeah we discussed at some point I'm going to
be kind of focused
so
recommend a 71 system programming I made a
video series about it
again my opinion is somebody who wants to
get into programming as if it should be
somebody who wants to understand the
terminal lots of people disagree if some
people think you should learn typescript in
JavaScript and you can go for that right
mr. Yeah too much sun dinner is crap
yeah people can use if I don't
set a tent lab
yip yip yip yip
the camera
all right I think of that got that
are there key
alright so here we go we have me I'm going
to read this out loud while I'm riding it
is it going to cuz we're going to cover get
home pretty early on
in the Boost we always do get him just like
one of the things that cover the first week
because it's the place to put all your notes
and but that also means we'll be creating
other repos in there eventually as well
the first one of the most important
Maine CDC important Rivas every text should
have on get him
and I mean get him so I'm going to put in a
related set here
no I don't need to sleep I already did I
slept like four hours
American missions here we go
LG Branch image images of different so
good night everybody here that if you're
just up for then I'm going to see you do you
like to visit
Suzette about.
About how to use. Or to use the dog may be
right about that in a second
so if you have his username user one you
should have.
Is that collab and I believe a CV
you know you can put your CV
underneath your your own but I I kind of
think having it separately is is valuable
I just do because then you can Nike track
all your changes to it without having to be
a mess
I don't have that currently in something I
need to reorganize
Especial repo
hey ironically this is
your website for you and this is
your your personal site uh-huh
they're totally different
all right
do do do do do
what's this one
it can kind of do it the same
I got repo
hookshot here at the whole thing I tend to
do that
I knew that too
exit group I didn't realize that for that
particular thing
oh God yeah
how's it going doctor professor
a pop in the VR have fun with that
soundtrack
heard you got one let me know I like this
one though
Dark Knight Trilogy Ultimate cut
ya look at that
on specific topic
yep Paschal candle shop
all right Sia so
there how are you I get cold
tell her bash no I did a little bit on the
Boost
KB on the bus there is also a book
and I'm going to be doing a lot of passion
in the boosters for this week in 2022
this is a free book you can get as well that
teaches bat bash stuff
2 2 2 2 2 2 2
I foresee no we're not going to we canceled
it
I mean it's a good book you can go do it but
I don't have time
I got to cover more important stuff when it
comes to our containers and less communities
infrastructure engineering I mean a focus on
that we will do see we're going to learn see
when we code when I'm going to code in C
either in a structure engineering or any
containers Sarah are here I'm going to do a
little bit of it
they're not going to be going to be doing
see here as a rule
because if it's not anything that isn't
going to
people need to learn to see it yeah she's
one of those things where if you want to
layer it on later you know
yeah
anything that's not going to immediately get
you closer to a job as a cloud native
infrastructure engineer
is that's the priority so honest enough to
score if we were to do an evaluation of any
particular topic and if the score is higher
than its Amore essential thing for you to
learn to get a job as a condiment Junior
it's always going to fill it's going to fit
in and see a certain amount of C is in Port
for understanding but it's much more
important that you understand estrace and
system calls which RC but you have to
understand what they are and and it's way
more important week of those things
yeah I'm learning how to use make a compiled
software that that is a big part of
infrastructure engineering so we're going to
be learning how to compile C code but
necessary to write it because that is a
truly essential skill if you're going to
install the systems and applications you
need to know how to compile it and generate
it and you know Jen to and that kind of
thing so this is a pretty pretty pretty
contrast from how I did it before but I
think it's important because you only have a
year there's just too much stuff to cut her
call generation programmers. Macias true if
how's it going mad
all right I think it probably needs a date
to do scmg stuff
tots
how do I say yes
booty Maxx Bash
okay
yeah it was a great great language to learn
to code in I think
I really like that for even for beginners
what's up sis calls Daniel Webster
I hate those things man
there I saw
I'm going to stop putting tags on their
completely
all right
I made a video about that let me know though
oh my God
that's so ugly
I don't work right now I'll be back in a few
minutes
dum dum dum
yes sir make your mother cry
Ida main thing I want to get out here
actually I can probably find a firefly
soundtrack let's go find it
oh my God I just have a soundtrack
there we go
I saw you with the NFL thing over and that's
good
I mean I like about the idea of having a
single lab like this is it you can go look
at somebody else's lab and see everything
that they've explored you know if it doesn't
fall under its own project
2 2 2 2 2 2
I'm going to buy the rest of my stuff over
here
we have God so many things gah
delete lab nfhs
vagrant
are you so status add and access
the push
yeah I don't like like I don't like
I don't I don't like Lincoln
yeah you people should have that
cuz that would be such a huge red flag if
somebody didn't want you to have this Eevee
with your LinkedIn
or something that would be so bad
a kidding me thank God I'm not interested in
any of that
it's just so stupid
yeah that's what I'm that's that's when
at-will employment becomes a really good
thing
are you looking to move you can go take all
those your ideas and go to some of their
start-up oh my God how do you deal with that
how are you doing that I could not do it
Newport in a normally long resignation 10
minutes in some countries
well I guess we have it nice then I guess we
have it nice
I do some of the clean up here I'm just
going to go ahead and and do it
I am cleaning is that a thing that I'm doing
I think I have
where is cleaning I don't have any cleaning
I have a cleaning title I need at 1
cleaning should I use a sponge or should I
use a broom Isaac Brown
I am create cleaning
I do not have an emoji Hast a broom
cleaning up what category just chatting
what tag should I use
the river and meet the head of such a great
soundtrack
achievements acoustical bosses amama
what else valence beginners behind scenes
body positive business casual chatiw chill
easy editing Educational Center English epic
evil for family first play Game Dev good
graphic design hard hiking interviews
my phone this movie I should always have
Lennox
music how he's a Taurus play Universal safe
space spirituality
vlogging Hip Hop
description
to go to do to do intervalle you or from
and don't know from value
none yes I am cleaning
copy pace hey it worked what do you know
what do you know
so let's go ahead and do that for a minute
clean
living on the labs over I think so he's
alive can be thrown away like my lab for
ansible Workstation
I don't think we did much with that answer
the question why I'm supposed to get out of
credit
graverson machine somehow perfectly is work
manager
I saw openssh-server is Ulta open in since a
fancy ball python with ping an ad hoc
commands for an Epson texted you first
ansible
and I don't think I'm going to do that
I have sent
are you watching music procrastination well
I'm sorry
and remove the ends of the lab I'm going to
a G8 remove it to
in the second plane GH3 bow
no change still lab ansible Workstation
all right that was gone Nick command
registry
a way to use a niche evil images of side
effects could receive commands golfer Maine
I don't cut it in the top of them replacing
the mud
United Market provider you can't do that
anymore they stop that it's now blocked you
can't have replacing your directives at all
God damn this is old
cancel name in complex the race life stories
yeah
I don't know if I need this one honey
everything in there is cover
and the other stuff that I do
can I stay at work sweetie to keep this one
again this is an example of why the naming
that I have is going to be out of control
I need to move that allowed to go in it
our first loss this is make it actually
called go live go
I mean I like the stuff but it's not coding
music Eye Associates lab go
a do I go
and I'm going to move lab go and Nick
command registry until I'm / go
Annette and registry
him and I at command registry or maybe I
should have. Yet
alright so
I mean I like this because you looking like
wandering around your lab and see what it is
you've been working us like that
and go in it
affresh
all right one of our lives that we have
go interfaces oh God I think I said can I
get a lot of these things are to move
I don't know man I don't know
money got so go interfaces
a sample of an interface Arizona Center
Another Printer
interface that depends on the time in your
face
hey Cena. How you do that
remove lab go interfaces 2
labco inter interfaces
5 go interfaces not get
and Ashley interfaces
nice and remove no sew it still
what else we need wigs to do live go
Annette C MD registry
all right so those are gone
and how many we got lots got him enough to
go through a lot of these
that you know what this is going to be
cleaner and I'll be happy reference is done
I got chisme server
yes then go to CVS a really good one I love
it how the great lab
move lamb go TCP server labco tcpserver
and using channels oh my God channels are
crazy hard
then when you first start in there not I
mean you're not super hard you're a lot
easier than promises oh my God that's even
worse
tell Labs go TCP server
grammar parser in go God damn I got to go
read read all this again
yeah we were running our partial remember
this
he must come back to this
move lab grammar parser Tu Lam
go grammar anniversary
made it was I got started I didn't finish it
so and make sure you remove all of the
they get repo junk in their allies of them
but it is a sub-module that would make me
have a bad day
add
are you
hacking and V arguments
God damn I have a ton of these things
I have a ton of them I need to move my it's
going to make me lot cleaner that I kind of
had to be here all night doing this I feel
like I need to put a movie on or something
in fact I don't think I'm going to bother
you all forces
should we watch a movie while I do all this
cleaning you think I'll get in trouble I'm
going to do that
I'm just doing boring cleaning so I'm going
to watch Firefly
a little bit hopefully I won't get reported
yeah
he used to be able to
have a nice day on the top or something we
can't do anymore
how's it going to fall out
everybody's making a fuss
I don't understand the top
I thought Chrome did call outs
maybe have the old Vim and it comes up in
tiny by default
she's a horse ever
I'm not whoring
I think I'm slipping
I can't something wrong with my ear is it
only coming in one ear for you to
huh
I have to say it out loud why is it only
coming in my left ear so weird
I don't see where I can I'm getting
distracted about
and this requires a code as a euro
I like being a doctor that's important
walk away from the stable walk away from the
stable
not my fault she getting all lubed up walk
away from this table
the man they call Jayne walk away from this
table the man they call Jayne
god dammit James all pissed off now
oh shit public relations
I am in rice
where the hell is my link
oh my God she's so pretty she's so proud a
how many times I watch this of God
I don't even know at this point DJ
I brought you some supper one has lepers
it was unjust of him to say that
why are you because so few men are
because so few men are
Developer tools
god dammit you said picture in picture but I
guess it doesn't have anymore
Maui when I get there Kerry she's awesome
she's just so happy all the time
give me the job so far
I don't know why this doesn't let me unlock
it to every other
oh it's that ugly ass cop
boom let's see what a man owes I've liked
you will will die for
what the hell why you pissed off I got
exactly no time for games
you're a lunatic you're a grown fed you got
the wrong man and it's not me either
even though my face looks like I'm the guy
but I'm not Centerton
it's the ugly guy with the weird tongue
it's not my time Best Day Ever
are bound by tall cuz that's what a little
man says you're bound by the law
this age I was for Friday surfboard
you must think I'm a back birth you must get
on the ground Sun
fuck there's no video track
yeah pic of a complete bat birth yes I do
your list gave it away
everybody on this ship is culpable and damn
it all the other windows are
why is everybody yelling I'm dead
nicest person gets shot
what what the fuck I just look for the
conversation can find it
why is everybody so angry sobriety meaning
of o
not going to happen I'm not a preacher not a
preacher I'm a former assassin
actually I'm not just a preacher yes let's
do it
I'm just cleaning right now I'm not doing
anything important
dented on I'm going to let her die cuz I'm a
smart guy
no
wait is already in here
wait I've had success in the whole fucking
time apparently I did
keyboard shortcut
opt out again Electronics okie dokie
when is this because my I don't have picture
in picture on this computer I bet yeah
what do I know they ordered out of Siri
that's why I was so confused they aren't
they aren't yeah they were restrained that's
right thing
if they have put this character development
in this first one first it would have been
so much more important stupid stupid people
who released it so fucking stupid
yeah so stupid man I just like really stupid
and people have money and run television
companies are idiots
yeah I guess it didn't
and then any but he got all that he got here
he won he won
Joss Whedon one cuz then he went on to like
own the universe
yeah
I watch the making of making it movies a lot
and it's pretty clear that it's just so much
problems
I can't say yet can't believe I'm going to
do this
I'm actually going out of full-screen mode
oh no why don't I have I3 that would help me
this seems to think he's not safe along with
me Task Manager
it's not I understand this window you can
have you can have like all kinds of stuff
Serenity area yep
this is weird
you should get some sleep goodnight
who is this one yours is it true love
no it's just a crazy ass she's so freaking
crazy
Simon Simon
it's okay Spider-Man they're going to poke
holes in me
we're safe until we're not until we're not
do you fight back up a second season God
damn if they did that they would never do
that
they have to get Malcolm
they already did they already killed wash
off their date they destroyed their
their clout with their fans when they did
that
when it when they killed wash off nobody
gives a shit about it anymore and they all
love it they love anyway
yeah how much to understand my phone meaning
I want you to understand my for me
she was a gift
this whole conclusion is fallacious
it was a code
men of blue tansy blue two by two
how'd you do it
I don't know
and there's the plot for the rest of the
whole entire series
you hate the world of trouble
uh oh
keep on flying Tempe off of the next Depot
oh right April 1st that's Mena
I'm scratching my head as to why we had
dealt them
Marine people thing ship
Sir am I right
yes we do
uh oh that one hurt
ouch
that was harsh Malcolm I'm a dead man I
can't now
saw that coming saw that coming
I time I watched it oh I've lost count I
don't have to count this point
I almost have it all memorized he wasn't
specific as to how
damn you don't know a goddamn thing don't
they teach you how to lie and cop School
he wasn't specific as to how pain
pain scary scary the man they call Jayne
she's so annoying. Cough is so annoying I
can't watch him
Richard Oliver has to be
Lawrence it's going to cut on your type
dammit Lawrence dammit Lawrence
wish I could say the same Lawrence this is
very disappointing money
but you help me out here
does it mean to have to turn on the captain
yes well that will be an interesting day
there's no containment
I don't know how they do it but they
actually managed to make you legitimately
scared
of these Rivers I was like actually scared
of them they just built them up so much you
know
reverse
it got to love that you got to love that
theme song I mean come on that theme song is
the best
and if we're very very lucky they'll do it
in that order
I just they build it up so well
tell rapist then rapist to death
just like Silence of the Lambs
and if we're very very lucky they'll do it
in that order
Aero composites
why is that that's weird this is very weird
oh shit
reverse
or were they
can avocados in my sky so many quotes
so many quarts
shiny
University UCSF
I'm afraid to keep this one you are mean I'm
in
Cheech download Gates
I'mI'm a bad man
have faith in people I'm sure that'll work
out well
Cheech
to all of us
lost in the words we are he likes it my way
oh shit that was stupid
this is Craig is yours I have the time
Kira's dad
what do they totally got me on that
sorry I'm giving away this movie got me on
this one
I was totally like terrified
I'm a bad man
that's a lie detector
I do believe that woman's fixing to shoot me
again
there were two exchanged also certain
bullets
I like the open about it we can deal
god dammit
I do believe that one was fixing to shoot me
planning
yes we do I wish you were here first it is
her turn
it is her turn just like so many little
comments in this that you just totally
missed the first time you see it
it is her turn
on the tricks no prospects
that anus
oh Tavern avertisment and we're back
Pella cuz I'm right here
man they call Jayne
don't kill anyone if you don't have to
Psy oh hey
this guy is such a dick
trying to help me punches them pictures of
preacher and then beaten while I was already
unconscious I wish that dude got in just
like ground to a pulp and that his skin was
sewed into somebody's clothing
but that's how it happens spoiler alert he
lives
in the comics he lives you watch the show
you think he dies it doesn't he lives the
lawmen actually lives
nice hats
that's the stuff
God damn I wish you would die such a dick
such a dick
by proxy
I never walk away when I don't have to
nice rifle must be your best shot is called
you fry make it quick and painless nice hat
nice hat
a funeral good old cowboy shootout
why fall my phone reminds me of white
Orchard
no it is it's very unfortunate
22 choo choo choo choo choo choochoo choo
I hate tsheets a horse
then I get paid
I wish you got to fix my character maybe get
some under the big clear do the job
and then I get paid occur in your little
world
reverse the Grim Reaper as follows
pom pom pom
horse for horse
oh I know expanse is ready to it was it was
really
can you going to give me a Crazy Ivan
I'd it was it was in CGI hadn't been around
that long that's what's so amazing about it
Islands yes
are very skinny dim
you're probably script this one
not dead unfortunately
why don't you just be quiet a moment
ever since we crying for
permission to be excused sir I need this man
to come with all my clothes off
yeah yeah yeah oh my God yeah
something you see TV shows right
yeah
now it's real simple
pictures of Future 2 here's something you
can't do
nice all that did it how to save me a ton of
time
woohoo
we're good people
that's my good girl like a girl
permission
I want to spend to come rub my clothes off I
just got to Terrell my clothes off work work
work
o w e
out here
and I don't even know if we think was wrong
because the spiritual leader of the ship is
the horror recipe for
I know. I see if your phone look at it yet
need new ID page for something I knew I paid
you for something
God I just am so pissed that we never got to
hear anything about a shepherd
that's like my single biggest anger
that is my single biggest complaint
it's crazy
my your dummy cuz you're my sister
that'll be an interesting day
keep your sister from doing anything crazy
Define veteran veteran veteran
and I know you won't kill me in my sleep
to let me make a refi slices wants if I ever
kill you if you wake me and you be armed
had a good day
Define
belly dancers belly dancers are eternal
I live on the edge literally
I just thought they would be off to Edge not
my location maybe someplace in the middle
sickle-cell comments and nobody hears it's
like that's what makes it so good I got
words
piss pot
suspicious
hey your coats kind of a brownish color
on cell
I think you were burned with an
overabundance of schooling he just happened
to find themselves yeah
piss pot
I would love to know what he says there
I got to look that up I got to go like I
didn't fight no more best of luck though
true neutral
Trader Joe class
a grand entrance or not go amiss so there's
like so many good lines in this
is velocity now
I have that ship somewhere
I'm blowing a crater in this little moon
with no guns
haha
got us some crime to be done
pick a number cube ATM
make my eyes and take my hand away. Do not
stand
I'm in free the guy from me
coming back Skyfall
I'm almost done with my work here all
cleaned up
I can see the photo of serenity
persistent volumes
I'm so glad I don't have to click on all
that shit to do that
to do to do to do do do do mouse pad
turn off the pad in French and Latin
not many
cuz I'm cuz I'm a good person
yes why not
repeating religiosity to the fuzzy-wuzzies
got ain't where the hell that girl go
she said translation oh now this is a really
happy developments
oh God I didn't know that I got to learn how
to say that
there you go
compatibility of spirits and then you take
out and pick up there with their wallet
oh God oh shoot about shoe whatever that is
you're lonely pathetic dreams
whether or not I'm actually done for the
night so I'm going to I'm going to leave you
kind of high and dry here
I was able to organize the the labs back
into a centralized lab and
when I start tomorrow I'm doing the work
stuff with them like we're going to do
going to be
okay I'll be back to organising the booth so
that we start with me instead of Docker
containers so that's the biggest take as is
boring stuff but thank you for joining me
for watch a little bit of firefly hopefully
the twitch Gods will smile nicely honest
see you next time